- I've been diving since 1963.
I still get that thrill.
When I jump off the boat in the water.
I look at the shipwreck.
I think about the history it represents.
It's a thrill.
I only champion the cause
of protecting shipwrecks
to let people appreciate that a shipwreck
is really in the environment;
it's part of the environment that need
to be protected and they
ought to be accessible
to the public to appreciate ‘em.
My name is Professor Charles Beeker.
I'm an underwater archeologist
and a specialist for
marine-protected areas.
Hold on to that sucker.
I got a chance to go scuba diving
and immediately fell in love with it.
Bought my first equipment in 1966.
By the ‘80s, I got
involved in academics,
and I realized that these
shipwrecks are really finite.
Going in.
They're a porthole to our past.
This is a one-time event,
and it's a trapped fragment
of life for the people on board a ship
when the shipwreck goes down
that tells us about that time period.
We're at the Underwater Cultural
Patrimony Conservation Laboratory.
This is the national
laboratory that is involved
with the conservation of the
artifacts that are brought up.
This is just a fantastic object
from the days of Columbus.
This is a sundial and you can see
the markings on the
dial, the Roman numerals.
What I saw was numerous
shipwrecks that were
heavily impacted by either hobby divers
or professional salvage operations.
You go to the actual sites
and what you find there
is relatively little left.
If everybody went out
and picked up one object,
there wouldn't be anything left
for us to see in the future.
These shipwrecks really
deserve being protected.
I've really spent
my time trying to look
at a way and make sure that
another 30 years from now
others will have a chance to
see these finite resources.
I've been coming here to
the Dominican Republic
to work with the government
to establish our first living museum site.
We're showing that alternative
to taking these sites
and turning them into a resource
that's recognized and will be protected,
rather than a resource that's going
to be harvested and disappear.
And are you ready?
These sites are going to last.
They will be around.
They're not going away.
I'll be gone, they'll still be here,
and that's really a
contribution I'm very proud of.